-There´s been a lot
of news this week
on the Donald Trump legal front.
We found out
stunning new details
about a memo
one of his lawyers wrote
on how to overturn the results
of the 2020 election.
He sued his niece
over damning tax documents
he inadvertently admitted
were real.
His lawyers knew days
after the election their claims
of widespread fraud were B.S.,
and there are reportedly
more indictments coming
in the Trump organization
tax fraud case.
For more on all that,
it´s time for a closer look.
♫♫
It´s been so nice
not having to think
or care about what
Donald Trump´s been up to
these past few months.
It´s like when you finally
get a cast removed
and you get to shower without
taping a plastic bag
to your arm,
which is why it´s such a bummer
that he and everyone around him
keep hinting he might
run again in 2024.
It´s kind of like how Mets fans
are relieved
when the season´s over
so they can stop
feeling miserable.
And then they remember,
"Oh, right, the Jets."
But hey, look,
on the bright side.
At least the Jets
can only lose once a week.
They´re Thursday this week?!
That said,
even though it´s liberating
to have Trump out of the news,
it´s still important to hold him
accountable for his crimes
and prevent him from doing again
what he tried to do in 2020.
He´s still implicated
in multiple investigations
across the country,
as CNN pointed out
when they tried to list
all of his ongoing civil
and criminal matters
in a recent segment.
-He is still facing a slew
of different lawsuits.
We have a full screen that show
all the criminal cases
and civil --
I actually do not have time
to go through them all.
-Trump has so many
legal problems,
CNN doesn´t even have time
to go through them all -- CNN.
They´re a 24-hour news network.
All they do is the news.
It´s not like they hand it off
at 4:00 p.m.
to their baking show,
"The Knead with Jake Tapper"
or their 5:00 p.m. dating show,
"On the Prowl with the Wolf."
[ Laughter ]
And on top of all of that,
Trump is now suing
his own niece.
-Former President Donald Trump
has filed a lawsuit
in New York State Court.
This time, he´s suing his niece,
Mary Trump,
and three
New York Times journalist
over what he´s called
the illegal disclosure
of his tax information.
-Mary Trump said this
in response.
"I think he´s a loser.
It´s desperation.
The walls are closing in,
and he´s throwing anything
against the wall
that he thinks will stick.
As is always the case
with Donald,
he´ll try and change
the subject."
-Imagine suing your own niece.
I mean, fortunately,
his lawyer does have experience
suing family members since Rudy
sued his cousin for divorce.
But aside from the family drama,
there´s a crucial takeaway
in this case that
we should focus on,
because in filing this lawsuit,
Trump was forced to admit
that all those stories about
how he had lost tons of money
and paid virtually
nothing in taxes,
which he had previously
dismissed as fake news
were actually true.
For example,
you might remember that in 2018
the New York Times
reported that Trump
engaged in all kinds
of suspect tax schemes
as he hoarded the wealth
handed down by his father.
Then in 2019, the Times reported
that Trump had lost
over a billion dollars
in the ´80s and ´90s,
and then in 2020,
The Times reported
that Trump paid $750
in federal income taxes
the year he won the presidency.
In his first year
in the White House,
he paid another $750.
He had paid no income taxes
at all
in 10 of the previous 15 years,
largely because he reported
losing much more money
than he made.
He was in the Oval Office
as president
of the United States,
and he only paid $750
in federal income taxes
to the country he was in charge.
That´s like finding out Tim Cook
has an old Motorola flip hone.
"$1,000 for an iPhone.
No, thank you.
I will stick to texting in T9."
There were all kinds
of shady gimmicks
documented in these stories,
some of which amounted
to outright fraud
that could constitute
criminal tax fraud,
as the Times put it.
Yet somehow,
it´s at risk of being one
of those insane Trump stories
that just goes flying by
in history classes
decades from now.
Textbooks will be replaced
by little microchips
they implant in your brain,
and high school sophomores
will just sit there
as they download
the entire Trump presidency
into their cerebral cortex --
Impeached twice. $750.
Did the Carlton dance?
Anyway, the point is,
when that story came out,
Trump, as usual,
claimed it was fake.
In your tax return, sir,
does that sound right,
that you were paying
a couple hundred dollars a year
in federal income taxes
-It´s fake news.
It´s totally fake news,
made up, fake.
Totally fake news.
No, actually, I paid tax,
but -- and you´ll see that
as soon as my tax returns.
It´s under audit.
They´ve been under audit
for a long time.
They´re under audit.
And when they´re not,
I would be proud to show you.
But that´s just fake news.
I mean, the stories that
I read are so fake.
They´re so phony.
-Oh, man.
Remember that whole audit thing.
I´m sure that´ll be
wrapped up any day now.
The audit is taking longer
than it took to get
season 3 of "Succession."
You´re making us wait
until October 17th, HBO?
That´s like a month from now.
This is taking longer than
it takes Kendall to say,
"Uh...Dad."
Seriously, though,
whatever happened with
that audit, anyway?
I mean, I´m not an IRS auditor,
but I would assume Trump
would be the dream case.
If I were there, I would open up
every manila folder
they put on my desk,
like Charlie Bucket
opening a Wonka bar.
I mean, just like looking,
looking for Trump --
It´s the [bleep] golden ticket.
But no, we can´t go after Trump
for decades of brazen tax fraud.
Some woman named Lorraine
in Little Rock
wrote off a pedicure
as a business expense,
so let´s rain hell down
on her instead.
Lorraine feels more confident
when her feet look good,
and that does make her
a better travel agent.
So lay off Lorraine.
Anyway,
Trump called it fake and phony,
but in his lawsuit against
his niece, Mary Trump,
he was forced to admit that
he was lying when he said that
and that the tax documents
were actually authentic.
In the lawsuit,
Trump´s lawyers write
that Mary Trump
came into possession
of more than 40,000 pages
of highly sensitive,
proprietary,
private
and confidential documents,
including but not limited
to financial documents,
accountings, tax records,
income tax returns,
bank statements,
legal documents,
and other related documents.
So they´re admitting
the documents were real.
I feel like this should be
big news, but then again,
I doubt Trump supporters
are at home
poring over legal proceedings,
deciphering the veracity
of his claims.
"Honey, it says here the
tax documents were authentic,
which would imply, of course,
that when the president
called them fake news,
he wasn´t being
entirely truthful.
"It only stands to reason then
that he´s been lying
about other things.
Hand me the horse medicine.
I need to think.
No, no, no.
Not the pills.
The paste."
So Trump´s got
a mountain of legal issues,
and now we know that even
by Trump´s own admission,
all those allegations
of tax fraud from the Times
were based on
authentic documents.
With all that said,
at this point,
it´s clearly very unlikely
Trump himself will be indicted
or arrested for anything,
which is insane.
His company is accused of fraud.
He´s personally accused
of all kinds of shady
tax avoidance gimmicks.
Robert Mueller accused him
of 10 different instances
of obstruction of justice.
He was
an unindicted co-conspirator,
an indictment to cover up hush
money payments to a porn star.
He incited a violent mob
to attack the Capitol
and overthrow democracy,
tried to shakedown
a foreign country
to interfere
in the 2020 election.
His hotels raked in money
from foreign governments
and lobbyists
while he was president,
and he basically tried
to commit election fraud
by bullying the Georgia
secretary of state
to magically finding
11,000 more votes.
And yet somehow, as always,
he seems likely to escape.
-Do you think that any
of these have traction still?
-Well, I think on
the criminal cases,
no, I would not.
I don´t think
it´s likely Donald Trump
is going to get arrested
at this point.
I think there were
various places
that he could and should
have been charged,
from Mueller obstruction,
to January 6th,
to, you know, potentially even
with the Trump Organization.
But given the signs
we´re seeing from prosecutors,
I don´t think
it´s particularly likely,
unless something changes.
-Kind of feels like
we´re in The Purge,
except Donald Trump
is the only one
who´s allowed to break laws.
Like, he can just walk around
and do whatever he wants,
and the feds for some reason
can´t touch him.
At this point,
Trump could park his car
in front of a fire hydrant
and instead of towing him,
they just let
the building burn down.
So being Donald Trump basically
makes you above the law.
But being close
to Donald Trump does not,
which is why so many
of his aides and associates
have been indicted and why his
business and his various cronies
are still facing
serious consequences.
If Trump´s the bull,
his friends and associates
are the China shop.
Trump´s like a tornado --
no one ever catches the tornado.
But if you get too close to him,
you end up like the cow
on top of RadioShack
5 miles from your farm.
For example, the former CFO
of the Trump Organization,
Allen Weisselberg, has already
been indicted for tax fraud,
and this week,
his lawyers said in open court
that they´re expecting
more indictments soon.
-Just in to CNN,
this could be significant.
News from a pretrial hearing for
the former Trump Organization
CFO Allen Weisselberg.
Manhattan prosecutors
have charged Weisselberg
in a broad alleged
tax evasion scheme.
Just moments ago,
his attorneys said in court
that he has
"strong reason to believe
that more indictments
are coming in."
-He said that he just received
today a manila envelope
that he held up in court
with a bulge in it.
And he said within that,
he was told that there were
three million documents.
He said that these documents
were found
in a co-conspirators basement
and that they were
tax documents.
Man, this Trump tax case
has more twists and turns
than a Trump rally dance
and more wrinkles than
Nicki Minaj´s
cousin´s friends´s --
Guys, I know we´re all
rightfully focused
on other things,
but apparently, while
we´re not paying attention,
they´re finding manila envelopes
full of secret tax documents
in the basements
of Trump Organization
co-conspirators.
Who´s the lead investigator,
Nicole Kidman, in a shawl?
"I just found a passport
with a different name
in my husband´s lockbox.
I don´t know what to think."
"Well, he´s cheating on you."
"I just don´t know."
Okay, but it´s that.
It´s always that.
Then of course,
there are the Trump cronies
who are facing consequences
for their roles
in Trump´s attempts to overthrow
the results of the election.
This week,
The Times also reported
that even though Trump´s lawyers
spent months claiming
there was widespread fraud,
a lie many Republicans
and right wing media figures
are still repeating,
they knew pretty much right away
that their claims were
total bull[bleep].
-The New York Times reports
on new court filings
in the defamation lawsuits
against the Trump campaign
by Dominion Voting Systems,
which, according to the Times,
shows that the campaign knew
the claims made by lawyers
close to Trump
that the voting machine company
conspired to steal the election
were entirely baseless,
entirely made up.
-New information tonight
on the outrageous measures
Donald Trump went to to
overturn the election results.
A memo from Trump´s campaign
two weeks after the election
indicated the campaign
knew that claims
from Trump lawyers Rudy Giuliani
and Sidney Powell were false,
claims that a voting
machine company, Dominion,
had worked with
a software company,
financier George Soros,
and Venezuela
to steal the election.
The memo,
saying the Trump campaign
knew those were false claims,
was obtained
by the New York Times
from court papers.
-That´s right.
They knew it was all a lie,
and they pushed it anyway,
which is good news for Dominion.
Maybe that $1.3 billion they´re
suing for for isn´t enough.
If things keep going this way,
Rudy´s going to have to get
a job as a building super
just to pay off his legal debts.
"Your toilet´s clogged.
Damn, I was hoping
I could use it.
Here, let me get my plunger
out of my briefcase.
I get one on me at all times
in case I need to go
at my law office,
which is also a Starbucks."
All of this means
Trump´s lawyers
knew what they were saying
was a complete fabrication
when they went on TV
and made claims like these.
-What we are really
dealing with here
and uncovering more by the day
is the massive influence
of communist money
through Venezuela,
Cuba, and likely China
in the interference
with our elections
here in the United States.
The Dominion Voting Systems,
the Smartmatic
technology software
and the software that goes
in other computerized
voting systems here, as well,
not just Dominion,
were created in Venezuela
at the direction of Hugo Chávez
to make sure
he never lost an election.
It´s been organized
and conducted with the help
of Silicon Valley people,
the the big tech companies,
the social media companies,
and even the media companies.
And I´m going to
release the Kraken.
-At this point,
the Kraken is going to release
a statement distancing himself
from Sidney Powell.
"I don´t get involved
in politics.
I´m just out here
to sink a few tall ships."
Although it was nice
that we briefly got
to meet Sidney Powell
as another psychotic character
in this whole mess.
I assume she went back
to her original job
as the chicken from "Paw Patrol"
or the headmaster
telling orphans
they´ll never get adopted.
"You´re too old,
and nobody loves you."
Also, in retrospect,
it´s maybe a tell
that they knew they were lying
that Rudy is sweating profusely.
It looks like he just
walked in from a rave.
Even knowing that all
of these claims were lies,
Trump´s lawyers
still crafted a plan
for overthrowing the election,
specifically a lawyer
named John Eastman
wrote a detailed memo
laying out a path
for Vice President Mike Pence
to invalidate
Electoral College votes
and throw the election to Trump.
And remember,
while this was happening,
Trump and his cronies
were also coordinating
with a Justice Department
official named Jeffrey Clark
to issue a statement claiming
there was widespread fraud
in the election,
a plan for a coup that became
very close to pulling off.
-Stunning new details
on Donald Trump´s efforts
to overturn the 2020 election
from the new book "Peril,"
by Bob Woodward
and Robert Costa.
The authors report
on a two-page memo
drafted by John Eastman.
John Eastman
is a conservative lawyer
who was working
for Trump´s legal team.
It amounts to a blueprint
for a coup.
NBC News has later
obtained the memo.
It outlines how Pence
was to have disrupted
the certification
of the Electoral College results
and handed
the election to Trump.
Eastman predicts
an immediate backlash
and lays out Plan B.
He writes this -- "Howls,
of course, from the Democrats,
who now claim that 270
electoral votes are required.
So Pence says, fine.
Pursuant to the 12th Amendment,
no candidate has achieved
the necessary majority.
That sends
the matter to the House.
Republicans currently control
26 of the state delegations.
President Trump
is re-elected there as well."
Trump tells Pence this
about Eastman.
"You really need
to listen to John.
He´s a respected
constitutional scholar.
Hear him out. Listen.
Listen to John."
-I like that this was Trump´s
best attempt to sway Pence.
He´s like a husband
trying to convince his wife
to let him keep gambling
by inviting his bookie over.
"You got to listen
to him, honey.
He knows a lot about horses."
Not only did they have a plan.
They had multiple versions
of the plan.
They had a Plan B,
as if when you stage a coup
and it fails,
you get a second shot.
It´s democracy.
It´s not a claw machine.
"Give me another 50 cent.
I almost had the bear.
I think they made the claw weak
on purpose."
I mean, what was Plan C?
Have Sidney Powell strap
individual senators
to their beds
and sledge hammer their legs,
"Misery´ style?
"Get ready for the Kraken."
The Republican Party
is still very much
enthralled
to Trump and Trumpism,
with aspiring GOP candidates
pledging their loyalty to him
all the time
and mimicking his brand
of corrupt authoritarianism,
which is why it´s so important
to hold him accountable
for his actions
and make sure he
and his acolytes
can´t pull off next time what
they tried to do last time,
and that´s why we need
far reaching reforms
to our electoral system.
So if you´re a lawmaker
concerned about the future
of our democracy,
it´s time to get...
-Kraken.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♫♫
God´s Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV, aids, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you´re watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe.
Get vaccinated.
We love you.